si han sido bombardeos durante la
madrugada múltiples bombardeos e
israelíes en tanto en la franja de gaza
como en el sur del Líbano en respuesta
al mayor lanzamiento de cohetes desde el
Líbano desde la guerra de 2006 los según
las fuerzas y relieves estos ataques
aéreos impactaron túneles y
instalaciones de armas deja más pero
también se ha denunciado daños en una
vivienda rural y en un hospital infantil
en la franja de gaza la respuesta de las
milicias palestinas fue el lanzamiento
de 44 proyectiles desde la franja uno de
ellos causó daños en una vivienda en
esderos una ciudad de israelí lindera
con la franja Este bombardeo está de
momento en pausa pero Israel ha culpado
al Líbano de todo lo que ha culpado
directamente al gobierno libanés de todo
lo que ocurre dentro de su territorio
para justificar estos ataques a suelo
libanes mientras que beirut como bien
decías va a presentar una queja al
comité de seguridad de la ONU la misión
de paz de la ONU en Líbano dijo que
ambos gobiernos le manifestaron que no
quieren entrar en ninguna guerra pero
que también estas acciones advirtió
están llevando la escalada a un punto de
máxima atención y Federico respecto al
segundo ataque que avanzábamos donde ha
tenido lugar el presunto ataque a estas
mujeres y qué más ha trascendido
el tiroteo ocurrió en el Valle del
Jordán en el norte de las y Jordania
ocupada allí dos mujeres hermanas que
están en los veinteañeras fueron las
víctimas dos hermanas israelíes mientras
que su madre que estaba manejando el
vehículo en el que circulaban se
encuentra en grave estado en un hospital
de Jerusalén y está siendo tratada
múltiples disparos alcanzaron al
vehículo en el que se trasladaban que
luego salió de la carretera se ha
lanzado la búsqueda de los responsables
y también el Primer Ministro israelí
Benjamín de taniaku va a liderar una
nueva reunión de su gabinete de
seguridad para tratar el tema esto
muestra los múltiples focos de tensión
que se han abierto el principal ahora
también está puesto en Jerusalén donde
se ha reforzado la presencia policial y
también de drones para el tercer viernes
de rezos del ramadán es donde se espera
que lleguen unos de 100.000 fieles a la
mezquita de araxa que ha sido el origen
de esta nueva escalada violenta a partir
de las dos noches consecutivas de
redadas policiales en la mezquita el
tercer lugar del Sagrado de